HELENA SHAW
Dad told me you found something.
A dial that could change
the course of history.
♪♪
HARRISON FORD
With Indiana Jones, I always thought
that what would be interesting,
is to see this educator adventurer
fooling with the nature of science.
JAMES MANGOLD
In our movie, the relic is rumored to be
an invention by Archimedes.
The research that I found about
the Antikythera, really fueled me.
In the cave set, all the things that
Archimedes invented, the lever,
water displacement, all the mathematical
figures are all a part of the design.
HARRISON FORD
The story is an intriguing
intellectual puzzle.
JÜRGEN VOLLER
Doctor Jones. Get him.
HARRISON FORD
As well as a physically arduous film.
RENALDO
Indy!
HELENA SHAW
BASIL SHAW
Indy!
HARRISON FORD
I always prefer to work on
a physical set to a virtual set.
Physical sets bring physical reality.
KATHLEEN KENNEDY
Harrison wants things to be real.
JAMES MANGOLD
We spent weeks in Morocco
with these revved up tuk tuks
smashing down the streets of Tangier.
TEDDY
Turn left! Turn left!
JAMES MANGOLD
Then Sicily...
INDIANA JONES
Hang on!
HELENA SHAW
Indy!
JAMES MANGOLD
Sicily came to play because
it's where Archimedes lived
basically his whole life.
♪♪
JÜRGEN VOLLER
Fasten your seat belts.
HARRISON FORD
You'll always face the challenge
of bringing something new
and something different.
PHOEBE WALLER-BRIDGE
There's excitement and danger
and not knowing what's going to
happen next and the twists and turns...
it always felt like a real romp.
INDIANA JONES
Get back!
You stole it.
JÜRGEN VOLLER
Then you stole it.
HELENA SHAW
And then I stole it.
SALLAH
Give em' hell, Indiana Jones!
HARRISON FORD
I'm delighted for the audience
to see this new adventure.